I'd manager suing Starbucks but I hope
that she sues them into oblivion because
I think she really has quite a case but
on the heels of that episode we have
this story out of Oregon a pair of
employees at Portland's back to Eden
bakery were fired after after refusing
to serve a black woman okay that's the
that's the that's at least the headline
that you know that's that's the headline
that we're supposed to focus on is that
two people refuse to serve a black woman
so clearly it's racism obviously that's
the only explanation I mean they refuse
to serve
but why do they refuse to serve her out
because the store was closed they
refused to serve a black woman after the
store was already closed and they were
fired for it okay this this actually
happened they were fired for the crime
of closing the store at closing time
so for a little context the store closed
at 9 o'clock at night at 904 two
customers walked in they happened to be
white and they were informed that the
store just closed and so they were gonna
be the last customers this is pretty
standard procedure if you've ever been
to a to a store right at closing time or
a minute after closing time or a
restaurant or bar or something you may
be told okay fine you're the last one
right very often the first customers to
come in right after closing they will
get the honor of being the very last
once and they'll be told that or or
think about if you're in a grocery line
and the light has just turned off but
you you slide into the line quickly and
then many times the cashier will say
okay you're the last one so they were
the last once they were given that
distinguished honor and then a couple
minutes after that another woman woman
walks in she happens to be black and her
name is Lillian green she's informed
that the women in front of her are the
last ones in the stores closed so what
does she do she proceeds to take out a
phone and start filming and she starts
filming and she accuses a store of
racism for refusing to serve her after
the store had already closed this
apparently is the first time she'd ever
encountered the concept of a closed
establishment she had never Lillian
green has never heard of stores closing
before she had no idea that that
happened she was shocked by it she
thought that all stores everywhere are
open all the time so she took a video
and she was and it went viral and very
quickly the employees were fired now the
bakery owner John Blomgren
is his name which just seems like a
perfect name for everything going on I
don't know why it just seems like the
perfect name
so Blomgren issues a lengthy statement
on Facebook which has since been deleted
for some reason he issues a lengthy
statement
talking about why why he fired the
employees and you know explaining the
whole situation and it's an incredible
it's a truly incredible statement so
Blomgren says that he says himself that
the employees who denied service to the
black woman who came in after closing
they are not racist he says that himself
he knows that they're not racist and he
knows they didn't have racist intentions
he knows that too yet and I'm quoting
here in this situation it doesn't really
matter because Lillian felt like she had
been discriminated against so she felt
like she had been discriminated against
so it doesn't really matter what was
intended all that matters is how this
woman felt about he goes on to say that
sometimes impact outweighs intent and
when that happens people need to be held
accountable
since both Lillian and the clamoring
public we're demanding that these staff
members be fired that is what we did
putting these two women out of work it
was an incredibly difficult thing for us
to do especially when they felt they
were just upholding our closing time of
9:00 p.m. but the way in which they went
about it lacked sensitivity and
understanding of the racial implications
at work Oh
oh my gosh
so what do we have here and then by the
way Blomgren also also said in a
statement that's back to Eden bakery is
100% committed to being a welcoming and
supportive environment for all customers
who share our values of inclusivity and
dismantling the white supremacist hetero
patriarchy so it's not gonna surprise
you to learn that this is a vegan bakery
by the way you probably won't be
surprised to learn that but that's not
the point the point is that he admits
that the employees didn't actually do
anything wrong but all that really
matters is how the poor aggrieved
Lillian feels about it and he even
admits that he fired his employees
because of the clamoring public he went
he came out and said yeah I got rid of
him because of the pitchfork mob so
that's what I did you know what else am
I gonna do the right thing come on
you
so it matters what the clamoring public
wants according to Blomgren it matters
how Lilian feels what does it matter is
what actually happened that's the only
thing that doesn't matter here according
to Blomgren the only thing it doesn't
matter is the reality of the situation
that's what doesn't matter but the
hallucinations and the the delusions of
lily and green and the clamoring public
that's what matters so two innocent
employees had to lose their livelihood
as a sacrificial offering to the
aggrieved masses
now
how does this relate to
the situation in the culture generally
well because this whether it's this or
the Starbucks thing and I think you've
got a real precedent here with Starbucks
and with this I mean this is a really
dangerous president and it certainly is
making me very thankful that I don't
work in the customer service industry
and then when you add in all the stuff
with the the Christian bakeries and the
LGBT mob that's been targeting them
we'll see what happens with the Supreme
Court case that that'll be announced in
the next few weeks what a Supreme Court
finds against the Christian bakers then
we're really going to be in a position
where you just can't operate as a
business owner anymore in America
so this is the inevitable result when
people are empowered to interpret
something however they want to interpret
it and then impose that interpretation
on everyone else
this is what happens so look at it this
way in any human conversation or
interaction there are basically three
things there are three factors at work
here so number one in any two anytime
something is said to another person
there's three factors number one
there there is what is actually said
okay so that's one fact what did what
was actually said the second factor what
was meant what did the person mean when
they said it okay that's the second
thing
third factor what did the person who was
being spoken to what did they hear how
did they interpret it those are the
three elements of any human exchange
right now things go really smoothly if
all three of those things line up if the
speaker means what he says and says what
he means and the here here's what it
said and understands what is meant
that's how you have a successful human
interaction that's when you can give
each other a high five and say yes we
interacted as human beings in a
satisfactory manner because it's such
it's such a rare thing these days that
you really have to stop and appreciate
it when it happens but a breakdown
occurs when one of those three factors
falls out of step with everything else
when there's a disharmony among those
three factors so if what a person says
doesn't line up with what they mean
there's going to be a miscommunication
and if what a person hears doesn't line
up with what was said or what was meant
then there's a miscommunication but
here's the thing okay this is the this
is the really important point but I want
everyone to we all need to understand
if I speak clearly and honestly and I
use the appropriate language to convey
my meaning
and yet you hear something entirely and
completely different from what I said or
meant that's on you that's your fault
that's not my fault
I don't need to apologize for it I
shouldn't get fired for it
I'm not responsible for your
misinterpretation in that case I have
done my job I said what I meant I said
it clearly and that's all I can do now
the balls in your court
I cannot be held accountable for your
unwillingness or inability to understand
something that was clearly communicated
to you so if I say to you for instance
oh I'm sorry the store is closed for the
evening I can't serve you
that's a clear that if I say that that's
a very clear statement and any person
with at least more than seven or eight
brain cells in their head understands
what that means it's a very clear
clearly conveyed idea so if that's what
I say and that's what I mean
and that statement indeed reflects my
intentions and my meaning and yet you
here yet what you hear in your head is
we don't serve your kind here get out
this is for white people only
if that's how you hear it when all I
said was it was we're closed and you
hear that this is a store for white
people
we're segregated well well that's your
fault that's on you I shouldn't be
punished for it
you're the one who owes me an apology
for wildly misconstruing some very
simple statement you owe me you should
apologize to me I demand an apology from
you in that case because I did my job
you didn't do your job which was just
simply listening to what I said and
understand it so likewise if I say oh
these tables are for customers only I
need you to buy something if you're
going to sit here which is what the
Starbucks manager said to the two black
gentlemen that were at the Philadelphia
Starbucks if I say that and you hear
only white people are allowed in
Starbucks
yet again that's on you that's your
fault you owe me an apology for
misconstruing what I said
I communicated my meaning and intention
as clearly as humanly possible yet you
snatched it out of the air and twisted
it into the weirdest little pretzel that
you could and then you beat me over the
head with it you now I need the apology
I am the victim in that scenario not you
you're the bully
you
my only job in an exchange with you is
to convey my meaning clearly and
understandably your only job is to
understand my me if I fail to be clear
you know if I communicate in a way
that's very vague and doesn't make a lot
of sense then your misunderstanding is
my fault and I owe you an apology
but if I do my job well and if I do
everything I can on my end then the
balls in your court
court and if you mess it up and you and
you you bungle it somehow well then
that's your fault
so mr. Blum Darrin says that all that
matters is how Lillian green felt no
that's precisely the thing that doesn't
matter that's the only thing in that
situation that doesn't matter what
matters is what matters for the in the
case of the the bakery two things matter
number one that the store was closed and
number two that the employees told her
that the store was closed that's
literally all that matters those two
things that's the only that's it
precisely the thing that doesn't matter
is how lily and green felt doesn't
matter how you feel about the fact that
the store is closed
makes no difference whatsoever that is
that's not my job to to somehow protect
your feelings in relation to the fact
that the store is closed what am I
supposed to do what were the employees
supposed to do I mean are we gonna go
they should they take down the number of
every racial minority in the Greater
Portland area and call all of them
individually on the phone before closing
to ask them if it's okay if they close
is that's what their supply guess yes I
guess that's what they're supposed to do
at this point that's that's that's what
is required now if I say hello to you
and you feel like I just called your
mother fat well no I don't know an
apology to your mother because I didn't
say that
now you can claim that yeah you said
hello but what you really meant is that
my mother is fat well you can claim that
and I guess there's a possibility that
you're correct I can't prove you wrong
because you you can't read my mind and I
cannot prove to you what was in my mind
but that is not a reasonable
interpretation of the statement hello
you see it's not something reasonable
for you to assume it yes in there is a
world in which possibly I mean someone
could say hello and they really mean it
as an insult against your mother I guess
but all we can do is reasonably
interpret the behaviors and statements
of those around us
that's all we can do this is not a
reasonable interpretation so I don't
know in your apology if I if I tell you
that it's raining outside and you feel
like what I really said was it's
stunning it's sunny out or if I say it's
raining outside but you feel like my
intention was to tell you that it's
sunny and so you walk outside without a
jacket on without it without an umbrella
and you get drenched the fact that
you're drenched is not my fault your
fault I told you
again I did my job
this has become I mean this this is
maybe the number one problem with with
the way
with our communication in this country
it's it's it's the number one source of
all the miscommunication is that people
think they have the right to just to to
essentially tell you what you meant by
what you said or did that's what they
you say something someone hears it and
that person thinks they have the right
to tell you what you meant
and if you try to clarify and say no
this is what I really meant it doesn't
matter they'll accuse you of meaning
something and it doesn't matter you
could try to clarify it all you want in
their safe now it doesn't matter but how
do you know what you meant I know what
you meant you don't know what you meant
who who's going to be the authority here
on what you were thinking me are you
will obviously me
know what matters is what is said
and yes the intention behind it
but you cannot impose or imbue a
statement with it with unreasonable
intentions or intentions that are
completely disconnected entirely from
what was actually communicated
so now let's let's up very quickly you
know an example on the other end of the
spectrum okay an example on the other
end the spectrum let's take the roseanne
situation from a couple days ago so she
tells a joke on Twitter saying that a
black woman is a black woman who was
born in Iran is the love child of the
Muslim Brotherhood in Planet of the Apes
okay now later she claims that she
didn't mean that to be racist but in
that case it is very reasonable for
people to interpret a comment like that
as racist that in fact is the most
reasonable interpretation of what was
said so in that case even when she comes
back after the fact and says oh yeah I
said something blatantly racist but I
didn't mean it in a racist way well know
that that doesn't work because now
you're being the unreasonable
in that case you said something very
clear your statement was very clear you
said a black woman is the love child of
Planet of the Apes that's a clear
statement and the meaning is very clear
and now you're trying to backtrack later
and you yourself are trying to imbue
that statement with a with a meaning or
an interpretation that is completely
disconnected from what was actually said
so yeah you can't do that either
so like if I say to you your mother is
fat and then later I say no no I just
meant to say hello
well no I can't do that because it's not
what I said if I wanted to say hello I
should have just said hello
roseann was trying to claim that she's
just trying to say that valerie jarrett
was ugly or something like that she was
trying to make a comment about her looks
which I mean is still not a nice thing
to do but that's not what she said she
could have said Valerie Jarrett looks
funny she's ugly I'm still not a
necessary thing to say but she could've
said that she didn't she said very
specifically
she's from Planet of the Apes so that's
you know traces
so we all have a responsibility in this
in this regard to say what we mean and
to use language that clearly conveys our
meaning and as long as we have done
then
we're in the clear
and however people misinterpret it or
whatever they do with it they take it
they put it in a blender they turn you
know they they slice it apart they do
whatever you know they make a
Frankenstein monster out of your
statement
that's all
or at least it should be
all right I think I hope I conveyed my
meaning clearly enough thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
Godspeed
you